digamos que tenemos por aquí una matriz
a qué además sabemos que es una matriz
tiene a filas y tiene de columnas y lo
que vamos a hacer es multiplicar esta
matriz por la matriz identidad
esta matriz identidad y por supuesto
como estamos multiplicando por la matriz
identidad lo que nos va a quedar es otra
vez la matriz de esta matriz que ya
sabemos que tiene a filas y de columnas
ahora basándonos en todo esto cuáles son
las dimensiones de esta matriz y bueno
pero propongo que le pongas pausa el
vídeo y trates de encontrarlas porque
además es un ejercicio que ya hicimos
cuando estábamos hablando de las
matrices identidad por primera vez claro
que en este vídeo esta matriz de aquí es
una matriz muchísimo más general no sólo
porque no tenemos sus entradas sino
porque además aquí las dimensiones sino
porque además aquí estamos hablando de
una forma muy general acerca de las
dimensiones de esta matriz entonces
ponle pausa y trata de encontrar cuáles
son las dimensiones de la matriz
bueno aquí podemos empezar por recordar
que esta multiplicación de dos matrices
solo está definida si el número de
columnas de esta matriz es igual al
número de filas de esta otra matriz
entonces como ésta se tiene a filas esta
matriz tiene que tener a columnas ahora
cuántas filas tiene que tener esta
matriz y pues bueno lo que sabemos de la
multiplicación de matrices es que para
que se pueda realizar esta
multiplicación el número de columnas de
esta matriz tiene que ser igual al
número de filas de esta matriz pero
bueno eso ya lo usamos ahora otra cosa
que sabemos de la multiplicación de
matrices es que el número de filas que
tenemos en la matriz producto siempre es
igual al número de filas de la primera
matriz y también es cierto que el número
de columnas de esta matriz siempre es
igual al número
columnas de la segunda matriz pero bueno
lo importante es que aquí hay algo muy
interesante cuando estábamos hablando de
las matrices identidad por primera vez
tomamos una matriz de 3 por 3 y lo que
obtuvimos fue que la matriz identidad
era una matriz de 3 por 3 estos números
a ive podrían ser cualquier número no
tienen por qué ser iguales ahora lo que
acabamos de probar aquí es que no
importa cuáles sean las dimensiones de
la matriz que escojamos siempre la
matriz identidad va a ser una matriz
cuadrada o sea una matriz que tenga la
misma cantidad de filas que de columnas
entonces matrices identidad sólo hay
matrices de dos por dos o de tres por
tres o de 50 por 50 y bueno generalmente
no usemos esta anotación de escribir la
matriz identidad como de 2 por 2 que
pues ya sabemos que es igual a la matriz
001 sino que simplemente lo ponemos que
es una matriz identidad de tamaño 2
aunque se pueden imaginar cuando estamos
hablando de una matriz que tiene 5 filas
y no sabemos cuántas columnas tiene pues
la matriz identidad que necesitamos para
esa matriz es una matriz y 5
que tiene 100 00
0 0 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 0 1 0 y 0 0 0 0 1
pero bueno lo importante es darse cuenta
que estas matrices identidad son
matrices cuadradas que tienen la misma
cantidad de filas que de columnas
independientemente de cuáles sean las
dimensiones de la otra matriz
independientemente de que las otras
matrices no sean matrices cuadradas y
tengan dimensiones muy distintas y no
tengan la misma cantidad de filas que de
columnas